Costco has a new product that they are
selling out of and that is gold bars I
love this story I can't believe this
exists Costco has everything they've got
everything and now they have bars of
gold that they are selling out of part
of the reason they're selling out is
because you know this if you're a Costco
fishion auto as I am if you get the
slightly more expensive Costco card then
you get 2% back and apparently you get
2% back on gold as well so you're you're
getting an effective 2% discount on
every ounce of gold you buy which is
pretty great but also what this tells us
is people don't have confidence in the
stock market this is an actual political
indicator